il y a la 24 qui vient de sortir un
Mario Kart 8 Deluxe comme moi vous êtes
en grand amoureux de Mario Kart il y a
la nouvelle vague qui vient d'arriver
avec pas moins de 8 nouveaux circuits et
un nouveau personnage avec les actes
précédents vous aviez déjà six nouvelles
coupes vous avez deux nouvelles qui
viennent d'arriver on a la coupe fruit
avec viré Amsterdam Riverside parking
Deska et l'île de Yoshi l'île de Yoshi
pour le coup c'est vraiment un nouveau
circuit mais vous avez également la
coupe boomerang avec Bousquet à Bangkok
le circuit Mario le stade Waluigi et
poursuit à Singapour sans oublier un
tout nouveau personnage qui vient
d'arriver c'est Birdo vous allez pouvoir
choisir dans différentes couleurs vous
avez en tout neuf Birdo ça c'est très
cool personnellement j'ai un petit coup
de cœur pour le Birdo Orange vous avez
tout par mois de 86 jouables sur Mario
Kart 8 Deluxe avec cette nouvelle vague
pour avoir accès à l'ensemble de ses
vagues il vous faut prendre un
abonnement au Nintendo switch online
plus pack additionnel tu coûtera 39,99 €
pour 12 mois à la maison c'est donc des
compètes endiablé de Mario Kart alors
bien évidemment sur les nouveaux circuit
mais sans oublier les battles ça on aime
les battles d'ailleurs vous je sais pas
est-ce que vous jouez à Mario Kart
est-ce que vous avez déjà joué plus
marquez moi tout ça dans les
commentaires et puis bien évidemment
est-ce que cette nouvelle vague vous
intéresse oui ou non marquez moi ça dans
les commentaires